[Musik]
selber schreibt meinem vater geht es gut
er darf morgen wieder nach hause lg
selber zum glück nichts zu sehen
dann ist es euer ernst eigentlich was
denn dass das chaos
darf ich vielleicht später aufräumt wo
also in einem monat
jetzt bleibt er ruhig nee du wird seit
wochen sorgen und ich sehe nichts davon
und den müll habt ihr auch schon wieder
nicht raus gebracht man leute ich habe
euch gestern gesagt bitte bitte bring
den müll raus räumt aufputz das
badezimmer und die macht muss die
flaschen wegbringen aber nein kann ich
alles machen kein ding
janina tut uns leid wir hätten keine
zeit kommt ich helfen
nein nico wir boni das schaffen wir
schon selber aber wir haben auch ein
zimmer frei oder das sind gute idee
was ist nico möchtest du bei uns
einziehen
[Musik]